the seismic shift for the democrats in
georgia
reverberated and was celebrated across
the united states
but the historic victory of reverend
raphael warnock
was perhaps best savored in the
neighborhood where he preaches
at the famed ebenezer baptist church the
wealthy
and the well-connected
have no shortage of representation in
washington
for the first time in 20 years georgians
are sending not one but
two democrats to the senate warnock made
history by becoming georgia's
first african-american senator and only
the 11th black senator
in u.s history after thanking voters for
putting their faith in him
warnock wasted no time addressing the
nation's covet 19
health and economic crises we are
dealing with folks who are facing
eviction people have been waiting for
months for relief
and they saw politicians play the same
old games last week
we should have already passed this two
thousand dollar stimulus check
and i can't wait to get to work to put
my boots on
and represent the people's concerns in
the united states senate
thirty-three-year-old democrat john
ossoff is the youngest member of the
senate since 1973.
he is the jewish son of an immigrant and
the ceo
of a documentary production company
let's
emulate the spirit of courage and
heroism
of those who have given so much to the
health response to this crisis
as we unite as a people to overcome this
challenge of covid19
and to build a republic that lives up to
our highest ideals of equality in god's
eyes
and equal justice under the law the
democratic upset in georgia
is also a victory for the army of
grassroots organizations
workers and volunteers who spent years
registering black and minority voters an
effort that never seized while
republicans were
busy attacking the governor and my boss
the democrats were out there knocking on
doors and getting people to turn out to
vote
republicans kelly lefler and david
perdue have yet to concede
saying they would exhaust every resource
to ensure
quote all legal votes were counted
between the november election and the
senate runoff more than
76 thousand new voters registered
the new georgia project says more than
112 thousand
people who didn't vote in the
presidential election
voted in this runoff that kind of
organizing prowess
will surely be studied by both parties
and emulated if possible in other states
natasha name al jazeera atlanta